okay great so are not Speaker of the bay
is my opponent he's going to scare us
supposed to be sound there we go
supposed to scare you with this talk
yeah I actually didn't even want to give
a talk but about this topic but I'll see
this talk so I got it for you yeah um
yeah also let me say mark and Alex I
know you're watching on the livestream
so thanks but remember you gotta go to
bath in bed after this is over right so
as I said I kind of apologize for being
here because it's not everybody's
favorite topic and like I guess I'm up
here just to scold you about these
things but I'll try to make it a little
bit fun throwing some fun facts in the
the course of the next half hour on this
subject
okay so here's some statements that I
collected from some published papers
I'll read them to you so this says the
SOS hierarchy can be solved in time and
to the order D for degree parameter D
the SOS parameter with algorithm primary
l takes n to the or L time to run this
one says if a degree yes DSOs proof
exists can be found in time n to the
order D actually I wrote that one
actually I wrote a couple of these right
so after reading all those statements
you'd be forgiven for thinking that like
the greedy solutions as how much
solutions can be computed and then to
the order D time by an SDP
well that statement is false okay
strictly speaking have to say like it's
not known to be true but it's partly
false but some people say yes yes I know
because there's the approximation right
you can't compute them exactly you know
I may be up to some like additive
exponentially small error you can do it
with CP but this one is also false and
if I could still false thanks the work
of Bend and Prasad even if all the
variables are constrained to be you know
boolean in your SOS program just plus or
minus one so that looks a little
unnerving
so let's actually let's back up the
truck before we even get to there and
you're really insult your intelligence
now by talking about linear programming
so I'll start the very beginning so the
linear programming feasibility problem
you're given a you
B these are rational matrices and
vectors and K is the set of points where
X is less than or equal to B you want to
decide is this a non-empty set or not
okay so is this problem in P in other
words is this problem solvable like on a
Turing machine in time that's polynomial
in the size of the input well we have to
think about what is the size of the
input and there's big complexity okay so
these are all rational numbers and it's
traditional to write L for the number of
bits in the inputs and I'm using this
angle bracket notation for like
literally the number of bits you need to
write down this mathematical object this
matrix of rationals in this vector of
rationals good so let me store that up
here and let's ask the question again so
is this consistent is this problem
solvable in polynomial time and in fact
before we even get there I know you guys
all know the answer but let's first ask
if this problem is in NP and first you
like of course it's nmp right I mean you
just give the point X that's the witness
for it being non-empty but of course
it's not quite as easy as that right so
it's not immediately obvious because for
example like the the prover has to give
you the points and you you know it has
to write it down so you have to first
ask yourself well if this is not empty
is there our rational point in this
polytope and furthermore it's not enough
further to be a rational point that ever
I you have to write it down with Pauling
Emilee many bits so you would like to
know if it's not empty does it
necessarily contain a point X whose
magnitude is at most exponential and L
that's okay that means you can write it
down with polynomial many bits all right
now I know you all know the answers to
these questions are yes and yes and you
can prove it by a very elementary linear
algebra but so Kate just want to say
that it's like not immediately obvious
that this problem is even in NP okay so
we know this fact you know before we get
back to P let me stall a little by
asking is this problem in Co n P and of
course the answer to this question is
also yes because of LP duality that's
nice so we know that given K you can
mechanically in polynomial time
transform it to another LP problem K
star basically the same size such that K
star is feasible if and only if K is
infeasible okay so then you can thereby
prove not prove that it's empty by
exhibiting a feasible point for K star
okay right so we have a problem that's
in NP it's also in current P so then
finally I mean it's historically I guess
how it happened we can
is it in P and yes it's in P you all
know this this fruit by Koch Eon and
then the proof details are filled in and
the same here by God's and love us
thanks to the ellipsoid algorithm so I'm
going to remind you a little bit about
the ellipsoid algorithm how it works and
why this problem is in P so the
ellipsoid algorithm takes as input two
radii these are going to be major
players in the talk big R and little R
and it also takes its employ at a convex
set K but it doesn't have to even
necessarily be given explicitly as you
know it's enough for it to be given by a
so called separation Oracle and what's
the separation Oracle it's like some
algorithm where if you give it a point X
0 the Oracle either tells you yes that
point is in K or it gives you back
you know if X is not in this convex set
it give you back a half space that
separates K from X 0 and of course if
you have this polytope ax less than or
equal to B in your hands you can easily
implement this Oracle for yourself in
polynomial time but really the or the
ellipsoid algorithm only interacts with
the polytope through this Oracle ok so
those are the inputs but there's also an
assumption you know I know you all know
this all this stuff but let me go over
it any way that either the polytope is
empty or it has two properties first its
contained in a giant ball of radius big
R centered at the origin and it contains
at least some ball of radius little R ok
so it's not just not empty but like
actually contains a little ball so under
these assumptions with these inputs the
ellipsoid algorithm either outputs a
point in K or it outputs correctly that
K is MP again we can remember how this
algorithm works you start out with some
polytope K by sumption it contains at
least some little ball of radius a
little R and the algorithm knows it's
inside this big ball of radius big R and
ok the ellipsoid algorithm it just
starts querying points so queries the
center of this ellipsoid and says is
this in K or not and in this case it
gets back know and it gets back a
separating hyperplane so the ellipsoid
algorithm puts the large or the smallest
ellipsoid it can around this region that
supposedly contains K and it proceeds
it's easy to show geometrically that the
volume goes down by a factor of like 1
minus 1 over N so we're making good
progress you query the center again it
just barely misses you get another
separating hyperplane
you put another ellipsoid around this
region in this case then you query the
center again and you found your point in
K or alternatively like maybe K actually
didn't exist at all it was empty so the
ellipsoid algorithm will query this
point and you know get back some this is
technically a separating hyperplane for
the empty set it'll keep going and it
looks like keeps shrinking and shrinking
in the case where K is empty until the
you know the algorithm realizes this
this ellipsoid is too small to contain a
ball of radius little R and now it knows
by assumption it can stop the K must
actually be empty okay so that's
ellipsoid and the running time of it is
polynomial in N and the number of hits
to write down big R and the number of
bits to write down little R and L which
is the max bit size that the Oracle
answered the the answer is that the
Oracle gives you okay so this is all
fine good ok so right so now to apply
this in case of LPS again it's not
totally immediate but it's not too hard
to show that using capital are being
exponential in ll surfaces which is okay
the LP doesn't actually have to be
contained in like a giant ball of radius
R because it could be unbounded for
example but you can get around that
quite easily and it's also actually
typically the case with LP is that like
they don't contain a ball of radius
little R because usually they have like
some equality constraint and they're not
even full dimensional but of course you
all know like a little wiggling you can
get around this too and some little
tricks too it's it's enough to show you
can show that it's a you can reduce to
the case where R is exponentially
smaller now and that's also okay great
so this is all some easy stuff right so
not only is the algorithm solve the LP
feasibility time and Paul mule problem
in polynomial time you also know that it
like have all these bonus features you
can find vertices you can optimize
linear functions the technology and band
Ernest and finally on time and actually
this is a cool you know extra bonus to
since the ellipsoid algorithm only
interacts with the LP through a
separation Oracle actually you don't
even need to have the polynomial
polytope in front of you and the number
of inequalities can be anything
em as long as you have a polynomial time
separation Oracle for your poly tope
okay that's very useful in combinatorial
optimization to optimize over these
polytopes that you only sort of
implicitly have access to this is great
everything about LPS looks good so to
summarize you know if you ask yourself
you know is everything I think about
everything I thought I knew about polyol
time lb solvability true answer is it's
true everything is everything you
thought you knew true it's fine
that's very quiet but supposed to be
dramatic I'll make the next one louder
wait okay okay although this is not
really relevant the talk right I like
this one facts I'll throw this out here
for you
you know this double bonus that gets
used a lot in optimization this is
actually pretty hard to prove like I
kind of explained it to you but it's not
as easy as that so this actually to
prove this requires the theory of
simultaneous tie fantine approximation
and like the LLL a lot of spaces
reduction algorithm
I think that's half the reason I Clovis
was interested in this a lot of space of
stuff so the thing that I always thought
was like I mean it from ellipsoid it's
actually very difficult to prove but
it's still true why it's interesting
question it's because like what if the
polytope is not full dimensional and
like you're a very bad separation Oracle
that keeps giving you parallel
separation to separating hyperplanes
let's split you at some point you have
to realize that it's low dimensional
even though you don't have K and like
jump into a low dimensional subspace and
some dyfan ting right so in the general
case when you just have that it's a
little bit embarrassing to well you just
have the separation Oracle you just
assume that you don't necessarily have
the big R in the little R but you've
seen the separation Oracle's answers
you're willing to run in time polynomial
in the number of bits they return
you okay so that's LPS everything is
fine what interesting actually okay so
now we have to move up to a CPS
okay so as you know an SCP is just
literally an LP except that the number
of variables is like a perfect square
and you think of the variables that's
being arranged into a matrix and you
always have this extra condition that
the matrix is BSC and the fact that
matrix is PSD is just equivalent to
these all these linear constraints on
the X variables for one for every well
real vector Y you get a linear
inequality on the X's so that's actually
kind of great it's like the situation we
were just talking about we have an LP
okay it's got lots of inequalities but
there's a polynomial time separation
Oracle that's no problem if I give you a
rational matrix X you can in polynomial
time exactly decide if it's PSD that's
not so easy to prove but it's been known
for a long time so great so it looks
like we're we're done we got the
separation Oracle so we should be able
to solve semi different programs in
polynomial time
it is unfortunately it's not quite as
easy as that because you know you go to
use the ellipsoid algorithm and you have
a separation Oracle but there's these
ARS the big R and the little R and this
assumption that the thing is either the
SDP is are they're infeasible or it's
contained in a big ball and contains a
small small ball and basically there's
no reason for either of these
assumptions to be true
you can do it like all over the
rationals exactly I mean it's not you
should have just like try to like you
know find a small second value or
anything basically your attempt to do
the cheol-su decomposition and see if it
succeeds or not no you'll actually even
see later how to do it in polynomial
time but yeah you do it entirely over
the rationals it's totally exact yeah
but you have to think about yeah okay so
for the little R problem these are all
facts that you I know you all know like
there are feasible rational SDPs where
the only feasible points in them are
irrational and for the bigger problem
you know they're also it's well known
there's feasible SDPs where they're
feasible but the only feasible points
are exponentially far away from the
origin
well doubly exponentially far away from
the origin and therefore writing down
those closest feasible points it still
takes exponentially many bits so I mean
these points together these facts
together make it even a drag for you
know asking yourself is this problem
even in NP and it's known if it's an NP
in fact I guess the experts believe it's
not an NP here's another fun fact though
here it's in current P if and only if
it's in NP because of duality and this
is the fact that I personally did not
know until recently but there's an exact
SDP duality theorem due to Romana
there's like no interior feasible points
there's no Slater conditions it just
literally transforms it into another STP
which is feasible if and only if the
original guy is feasible so it's
interested to learn that so we know the
problem is in NP if and only if it's in
Co NP but probably it's in neither so
then you might wake say whoa whoa is
this problem even decidable and yes it's
decidable by reduction to the
existential theory of the reals but
that's basically the best thing we know
not that it's just a side wall but by
using this fact so it's also nice for
SOS lovers that there's a great paper of
these heroes grigoriev in frog drove in
88 they showed that this central theory
of the reals is in X and then a similar
time candy showed this in P space so the
semi definite program feasibility
problem is in P space and that's the
best complex the upper bound we know
again I apologize if you know all this
stuff but these are things that like I
myself only
you know discovered kind of recently so
I bring it up okay but we're here to
talk about SOS you might say what about
just sum of squares testing so here the
problem is you're given a multivariate
polynomials or the rationals and you
want to know if it's the sum of squares
and this is a special case of SDP
feasibility testing for this you know
particular polynomial right here I just
wrote it down if you want to know if
it's SOS it's literally if and only if I
mean we saw this in the previous talk
for example or to talks ago some matrix
M is PSD such that this M satisfies some
equality constraints whether or not this
SDP is feasible is equivalent to asking
whether this polynomial is SOS so it's a
special case of SOS feasibility but as
far as I know it's not known to be any
easier
so in fact the best upper bound on
deciding this problem that I know is
pspace that's kind of a drag too and we
can just review like why it may still be
a problem so there's this the little our
problem first of all this SDP is never
full dimensional at all because it has
all these equalities to get the
constraints the the coefficients right
so it's it's never going to contain a
ball of radius little R also it's an
unrelated issue this particular
polynomial right here is an S is SOS
over the reals but it's not SOS over the
rationals so let's prove recently and
again it's gonna kind of make it tough
to imagine that this problem is in NP I
mean it could be but this is a some kind
of barrier to it and uh there's also the
bigger problem I actually personally
don't know if this is an issue or not
maybe I'm maybe somebody in this
audience knows whether it's possible
that like a polynomial is a sum of
squares but there's no way to write as a
sum of squares using numbers that are
not enormous I don't know if that's
known or not so the big R problem could
also be like a fundamental barrier here
too
you can bound it okay good yeah I'm glad
that well I mean oh well I mean just
whenever you cook up the SCP that looks
like this right it has all these
equality's so it's not gonna be a full
dimensional the feasible region if it
exists it's not gonna be a full
dimensional region of that's not even
when you do LP right you don't say that
it's that it's full the National thing
of the of the non-negative or thing you
want it to be a full dimensional in the
ambient subspace in which you slice in
the relativity
yeah I mean if you want to I mean you
know just use a lip sight out of the box
right like it's supposed to have a you
know full dimensional little ball in it
so yeah there's reductions to get around
that in LP and you can attempt some I
guess reductions here to get around it
but yeah in that formula just part of
the various assumptions yeah yeah okay
good yeah so B I'd be interested to hear
about that okay but then you might say
well you know I'm really an optimization
person it's not like I'm like dying to
know if it's exactly a sum of squares
like maybe I was just trying to certify
that it's not- and I wouldn't mind
certifying that it's at least negative
epsilon and that's cool to me I'm not
sure if that exactly makes sense by like
scale and variance I mean so anyway
let's let's recall the SOS method you
know it really dive into this this
question about let's say approximate sum
of squares testing so we've seen it many
times so I don't have to recall it too
carefully but the problem here is you're
trying to maximize some polynomial
subject to some polynomial
equality's and some polynomial
inequalities and just assume that all
these input polynomials are really low
degree like three or something and of
course this encodes lots of natural
np-complete problems okay so the SOS D
method with parameter D is to try to
certify that R is at most some number
beta on the feasible region by writing
it like this we've seen this before you
want to write beta minus R and this sort
of like obviously a manifestly positive
way where this a then B is and C is
sorry the A's and B is RSOs
the cia's can be any polynomials and if
you can find such polynomials of degree
at most D then that certifies that R is
at most beta on the feasible region D
works ok and the existence of these
polynomials is indeed an SDP feasibility
problem of size and to the order D so
polynomial size of D is a constant and
let me even make our lives easier
typically an optimization you know you
don't mind mind including often don't
mind including inequalities that keep
everything bounded like XY squared is at
most one for all eyes this makes it
compact that makes everything nicer so
let's just always even assume this okay
then there's some good news
the good news is that the little art
problem in this scenario is no longer
really a problem okay so basically even
though you know the SDP has all these
equalities and so forth and inequalities
you can like fuzz the feasible region a
little bit so that it contains like a
small ball of radius R are being like
exponentially small and then if you get
back a fuzzy certificate
oh this is a little annoying that I use
capital R here here I meant the
polynomial that the polynomial R is at
most beta then you can fix it up to get
like a genuine certificate that the
polynomials at most beta plus something
that's exponentially small in this
region this is using the compactness and
you know an optimization that's probably
enough for you so that's fine but the
bad news is that the bigger problem it's
really unfortunate notation choice by me
the bigger problem is still a problem in
particular this is a very trivial thing
I wrote down recently you know there's a
degree to instance of like an SOS
optimization problem with these
constraints where even any approximately
good certificate that like certifies the
optimal value to like an additive 0.1
requires you know coefficients that are
in the Esso a certificate that are
doubly exponentially large okay so
cannot be written doubt with Pauline
really many bits there either all here
on one or maybe they're between integers
between 0 and n so they're tiny they're
all 0 or 1 or 2 actually so yeah these
these equations this consistency
equations try and put for your notions
you still require that they are
satisfied with equality yeah in the
instance yeah thing if you drop that
lots of approximations they are then
well you can uh you can that's okay I
mean actually you can fix if they're not
exactly satisfied as equality you can
actually fix them up to be satisfied
exactly as equality is so you in this
compact case so it's not that yeah it's
somehow in this instance it's not like
satisfying the equalities exactly is the
issue it's just that like the only
certificates really is like doubly
exponentially large numbers that's a
good question yeah for a degree two
certificates so the point is that there
exists a degree two certificate that
this you know instance I wrote down has
you know minimum it's a minimization
problem zero but like any degree two
certificate that certifies it's at least
negative 0.1 requires these WI
exponentially large coefficients and
actually in the follow-up paper by
Prasad he points out that actually in
this particular thing I wrote down
there's a degree four certificate that's
small coefficients and you know gives a
good bounce
but then he gave like a worse example
where like even if you go up to a degree
routine like you can't get anything good
so this is the impact the baton is so he
gave like wrong event Ron Weiss gave
like a much worse example for two
reasons one is even in the case where
all the exact boolean equalities are
included so you're not just optimizing
for a compact region you're just
optimizing literally over the discrete
cube and he gave to some degree to
instance they gave some degree to
instance where even to certify the true
minimum to some constant additive error
you require doubly exponential
coefficients and that remains true even
if you try to use up the degree I think
Rudin
so I threw them exponentially large in
size but low root n you need
exponentially large bit size to get like
any approximately correct a certificate
even though there exists like a perfect
degree to certificate but it just the
degree students are to surfing it uses
enormous numbers well the man is sitting
right next to you not in this short
amount of time but this example is
literally it's literally nothing more
than taking like the very classical SVP
example of like a feasible SDP that
requires where all the feasible region
requires like W exponential size and
basically massaging it into an SOS
situation where this approximately
situation still holds true actually as
Pablo pointed out to me like any SCP
feasibility problem at all can be viewed
as like a degree to sum of squares
problem modulo an ideal so like as soon
as you have like any bad thing happening
in SDPs you basically arguably is also
happening for for SOS okay so ah there's
some good news it's not all bad news
this is some good news when these are
the only constraints you have the only
constraints you have our boolean
equality so you're just optimizing a
polynomial over the hypercube then
everything is okay okay everything
that's okay so like Komen's williamson
max cut algorithm
okay and it's actually you know this is
one other fun fact i like to tell people
this fact that domes williamson is okay
what's proved by the alarm and pull jack
in nineteen ninety four years before the
guns williamson paper i love this paper
it's a great paper so they proposed the
degree - SOS certificate method for
upper bounding the maximum cut in a
graph and then they were like chapter 7
and existence of a polynomial time
algorithm and they're like they got the
big are the little are they got it it's
all in here the rationals that are
appealing to like the ellipsoid
algorithm here they're showing that like
testing of a matrix is BSD can be done
in polynomial time actually they made a
mistake here they said that a matrix is
PSD if all the principle minors are PSD
which is false but it's close to being
true and these heroes back in nineteen
actually correctly showed that this is
the proof that you can test if of matrix
as PSD in polynomial time right here
yeah so it's all fine you can you can
you can handle this case so optimizing a
polynomial over the discrete cube with
the SS method is okay and again this
hero it's wrong a venture on why it's
showed some other ok cases in this
recent paper
so like optimizing over the cube with
these plea constraints it's okay so like
everything let's Sam and Aaron told you
this morning is okay and optimizing not
over to the screen Q but over the the
sphere is okay so everything vijay told
you today is okay and some of the things
like if you want to like impose like a
my section constraint on the hypercube
so like you want to maximize over the
middle Hamming layer of the hypercube
that's also okay even though actually um
like the Grosvenor basis for that is
exponential size you can get around it
it's okay so there are some more cases
where everything is fine and roughly
what they show I mean there's some
things you have to check it you should
check out the paper but roughly they
show when all the equality's that are
implied by sort of the input equality
inequalities when all these implied
equality's are easily derived in SOS
then everything is okay but sometimes
like the Equality inequalities imply
some other equality's which for like non
obvious reasons and that's the situation
where we don't know things that are
alright so in particular like let's say
you're in the context of you know
boolean CSPs
and instead of like trying to you know
maximize an objective function subject
to you know the boolean constraints you
instead start trying out different
values beta and asking hey is it
feasible if I impose the constraint as
an equality objective equals beta that's
kind of a natural way to use
optimization to try to approximately
solve in a CSP and that one we we don't
actually I don't know how to do that in
polynomial time okay so I'm basically
done and you know just the summary of
what we talked about here is this I mean
I love SOS don't you know I'm not trying
to you know scold or anything it's great
but just the only thing I want to say is
like if you if your goal life this is a
show that
problem is like if you're just trying to
like optimize a polynomial subject to
the constraints like sex I squared
equals 1 or x I squared equals x I the
discrete cube constraints but you're
trying to use higher levels of SOS
that's all fine those you can solve to
like additive exponential and minus n to
the D accuracy in n to the D time right
if you try to say like the max code is
you know exactly 6040 three edges we
don't know how to like test feasibility
or refute feasibility of that which it
is true that you can ultimately solve
within some squares
and so it's a it's the valence
keyboardist in duels like they try to
find moments there consistently the
point on the equations that you have if
you are in the compact sense in a
sequence so in this case is that so you
have this little R big R about this
almost we have certificates because
little R little R big R switches yeah my
understanding is that in the pseudo
expectations I like the little R becomes
the problem simulated our problem by
saying that you only want this pseudo
moment that approximately satisfy the
normal equations in that sense you can
approximately solve just like these dual
things then notion of what means to be
approximately solving HS and I think
maybe the way you can solve
approximately the sum square so it is
instead of producing a certificate for
the coin dealer you given only ticket
fall upon when you're given you're
producing not activities it'll be good
for who knew that is Louis similar
coefficients yeah I mean it's true that
like if you switch to the the dual side
you can find you know pseudo
expectations or whatever that like
almost satisfy all the constraints but
there's some oh I think a big difference
between almost satisfying them in
exactly satisfying them I mean if you've
ever and I know you have like you know
constructed like an SCP solution for
something that like almost satisfies all
the l2 squared triangle inequalities and
then you're like well now I want to fix
it so it literally exactly satisfies
them it's not like so easy right then
usually it's not a problem right
probably worth discussing later date but
yeah yeah I mean I'm only happier if
like everything has turns out to be fine
and when you want to certify in
feasibility of a system that's that's
when that word there's no sort of
expectation that we can compute if you
forgive a three-set system is infeasible
you are certified in fees of using sum
of squares boobs they sort of stuck in
this world we're stuck in this world
where it find a solution right then I
drew a thumb through it and then you
usually have some some algorithm that
gives your crowning algorithm it if so
it gets as input and now you know this
now the question is you know the sucide
rhythm depends on whether you supply the
equations exactly or whether you satisfy
them within exponentially small and I
think you should reconsider that we we
never use the technically exact exactly
solve the equations anything that needs
it also in you know even existed
let's not mention make these algorithms
they would reproduce a reasonable answer
even if there's no exact super solution
as long as you have this you know
exponentially good
I mean I guess I would say like this is
something that like you have to check on
a case-by-case basis and it's not
necessarily totally automatic like I
think it's not inconceivable that you
could be in a situation where it matters
if you satisfy something exactly or
merely very close to exactly you could
all I mean I'm sure it is the case that
like most the time it's not a problem
but like I don't know very compelling
reason why it will never be a problem
questions or comments thank Ryan again
[Music]